when Moyes was selling native deodorant
he didn't own the trademark and it was
an issue he's got the deal done and
they're like wait you don't have the
trademark he's like yeah but there's no
other native deodorant they're like okay
Junior what are you talking about that's
not how this works um you
[Music]
know all right today we thought it'd be
fun to do a episode all about how we
actually run our companies so we've been
running companies for like I don't know
10 15 years now and like many people out
there at the beginning we did a bunch of
dumb stuff and so we're going to admit
and confess to some of the dumbest
things that we did running our companies
and then talk about what we do now
that's actually like we found that works
so the stuff that didn't work and the
stuff that works and this is around you
know everything from like you know
mission statements how we used to think
that these were like super important and
how we treated them versus what we do
now or branding and naming our companies
or goal setting um these are kind of
like the shortcuts that we use now so
what what actually that we found Works
through the painful process of making
embarrassing mistakes that's what I
think we're going to do today yeah we
got about like five or eight categories
of like on hiring on creating comp plans
on having boundaries with Steph these
actually sound like boring when we're
like just when I'm just reading that off
but I promise you it's actually we have
like interesting stories behind each one
and stuff we wish we would have done
earlier that I deeply regret that didn't
do now or that I didn't do then but yeah
we'll we'll go through all the stuff
that we actually use on a day-to-day
basis to run our companies the touchy
feely stuff that's actually really
important so I thought it'd be fun for
us to share [__] we do when we run our
companies what are our almost like
management hacks or shortcuts or like
the methods that we use which as a
disclaimer probably not the best
probably not what they teach you in
Harvard Business School or what you know
like very polished you know seasoned
Executives would do I remember when when
I started uh one of my early companies
it was in my internal mission statement
was to hire 10,000 people and and then I
hired like two people and I was
like [__] hey does got a new racer yeah
yeah like how do I make this 10 uh it
was horrible um and then it was like um
and then the mission statement for the
employees is like look like we're going
to
change whatever like right now the word
is democratize we're democratizing the
financial markets or whatever it's like
whatever that equivalent is is what I
said like we're going to change the
world one newsletter at a time and so my
missions statement did you really say
that no but it was probably like as lame
I
don't that would be the worst if I said
that but no they're pretty lame now
they're way more um so here's what I
tell people I go here's my the mission
for the business this first one it's
very selfish which is I'm want to work
on cool [__] with cool people and have a
dope life that's just what I tell people
I go so it's very self selfish I just
want to work with cool people on
interesting things and that's more so
the mission than anything and then it's
like and if we are able to do this this
and this that will also be cool um
versus a far more Grand thing my mission
statements aren't nearly as Grand are
yours I'm in the exact same bucket so
definitely used to be like changing the
Status Quo you know on my Steve Jobs
[__] and you know because that's who you
looked up to looked up to Steve Jobs
looked up to Elon Musk and he's like you
know create an inter planetary species
it's like oh okay cool uh what's my
version of that like you I'm I'm not
trying to get to Mars and like make
humankind uh you know interplanetary but
I was trying to do that do but you
remember that story of Steve Jobs where
he's trying to recruit the guy from
Pepsi and Steve Jobs is like you're just
gonna sell sugar water for the rest of
your life
right [__] you
Steve what a dick now we're like Logan
Paul genius puts sugar in water sells it
to children
dude the audacity so I'm like you now uh
I here was here was the notes I wrote on
my answer for this uh my on my little
Chichi I wrote I don't Kid myself
anymore I'm honest I'm building a
lifestyle business for me and my team
almost exactly what you just said which
is I want to do dope [__] with cool
people right so do cool [__] with cool
people and in a way that leads to an
awesome lifestyle meaning I'm not trying
to kill myself currently running the
business and I'm trying to have a
financial outcome for me and my team
that lets us all Elevate our lifestyles
right like that's that is the this
business is a vehicle to have an
enjoyable lifestyle which is really
funny because in Silicon
Valley lifestyle business is the um it's
the equivalent of saying no offense uh
to start a sentence it's like lifestyle
business is how VCS Pat you on the head
and say that's cute uh oh oh one million
of Revenue that that's cute you know you
know we we we don't invest in lifestyle
businesses right if this is just a
lifestyle business for you we're not
interested right your your low ambition
which in Silicon Valley is where I live
is low status however for me I feel like
I broke out of the Matrix and I was like
wait what the [__] are all these people
talking about the point of life is to
have a great lifestyle what I don't want
another I don't want to do something
else with my life I'm not trying to have
a bad life I'm trying to have a good
life for me for my family for my team we
all want the good life okay let's do a
project that's fun and interesting with
fun and interesting people in a way that
we all get rich is that so much to ask
and so like that is now the blanket
mission statement on all of my projects
and um I don't know if that's inspiring
to the Troops but it's inspiring to me
and I hope that it just attracts people
who are down with that and not looking
for the uh the Rah you know save the
world I actually think I think that is a
bit inspiring to be honest to like the
right type of person um and uh I I at
least when I talk to people it seems
like yeah that sounds wonderful another
thing that changed with me is when I
start new companies I pick business
models where I can afford to pay hires a
lot of money because I remember when I
was starting a lot of my stuff I'm like
man I don't H I can only I I don't have
enough money to pay a high quality
person a lot of money I it's a trap yeah
I'm like I wish I could afford to pay
someone three or $2 $100,000 a year so I
could recruit a certain type of person
so I could spend time with them um and
so that has changed as well well like
what's an example so like the
traditionally you know media companies
uh when they start obviously they don't
make a ton of Revenue you're putting out
free content um and writers are
typically not that well paid however
like so would that count as it was more
in the towards the bad end of the
spectrum or was it on the good end
because you did hire people like Steph
Smith and Trung and H great people
eventually I hired great people
eventually but like for example um a
good media like you could you could run
your media company a few different ways
you could particularly for sellers for
ad sales people you could pay them 60
Grand a year and say they have a quota
of only
$400,000 and they get they make 105
Grand when they hit their On Target
earnings or you could go hire someone
who you're going to pay $200,000 base
plus a higher commission and their
expectation is that they're going to
sell two or $3 million worth of stuff
and typically those people who are more
competent and capable I find are more
enjoyable to be around and so like
things like that where I'm building a
business that hires less people who I
pay more because that setup I think is
more enjoyable so I had the same problem
because my first business was in the
restaurant industry and the restaurant
industry is basically like you know what
is what is the worst type of business
you could you could select it's probably
I don't know if it's the worst but it's
down there it's hanging out with the
worst whatever it is right so almost all
of them fail um even when they succeed
they have like 10% net margins typically
and you got to open up like multiple
locations to get to ever make it big or
have enough cash flow from a business
like that to higher high quality like
you know highly seasoned people and so I
remember meeting the guy who ran
Chipotle I think he was the CEO or COO
of Chipotle at the time and we were
trying to create the Chipotle of sushi
and I was like all right you know like
give me your advice I didn't even know
what question to ask but I was like give
me your advice and he's like well think
of it this way your entire product is in
the hands of somebody who makes $9 an
hour and doesn't want to be there and
and every C everything you're telling me
right now about how great the user
experience is going to be that's true
for restaurant 1 it might be true for
restaurants 2 and three by restaurant 4
it's no longer true because you're not
there anymore uh to do the all those
amazing things and give that amazing
user experience he goes the trick in
this business is whoever can figure out
how to get minimum wage employees to
give somebody a good experience uh they
you get you get to win that's the
winning condition he goes so you know
for like Chipotle we ended up doing a
bunch of things to try try to improve
that he's like you know I don't know if
we did it fully but like they did a
couple things like for example if
anybody if you're a manager at Chipotle
and anyone you manage becomes a manager
of a restaurant you get $10,000 whether
you work at that company or not just
like ever it's like you had a hand in oh
that's sick and leading that person to
be a to I don't know if they still do
this but at the time they did um they
also changed the title so like their
manager was called like restaurant tour
or something like that and they paid
them above market and they're like you
know we're doing all these things to try
to fix it Starbucks did the same thing
giving people benefits so that they
stick around and actually stick with the
job versus really high churn but
nobody's really figured that out point
is I remember it just wasn't a lot of
fun to be in that business because I
couldn't relate you know all the things
I love I'm an entrepreneur I'm thinking
about ideas or um you know raising
capital I got big goals Big Dreams and
I'm coming into work every day with
somebody whose goal and dream is to get
off work early that is the like there
that would be the the best thing that
could H happen to them at work that day
and I was like [__] that's not that
inspiring every day to like kind of and
I don't mean that to knock anybody it's
just the truth it's like you you're
going to hang around certain people when
you run a business ideally you would be
around people who are very very
like-minded to you in the sense of they
share similar values and goals and
aspirations and then it becomes
contagious and then they're sharing
learnings with you and like I remember
we interviewed I remember we were
interviewing people for like this
position because we kept having people
flake out they would just leave or they
would steal or stuff like that and like
my buddy who was interviewing he goes
well I like this person um they had all
their teeth I was like what and he's
like I don't know he's like I'm I'm just
looking for symbols I just he's like the
last three people stole from us and that
sucked I just want somebody's not going
to steal from us like that's my new bar
first and like after that I could figure
out a higher higher level requirements
and so did you see on um did you see on
the TV show bear where they hire this
you know this guy and on the first day
they catch him outside smoking crack and
they're like I think I need to fire you
but I I should go but I should go
ask yeah he's like yes chef fire
him yeah and by the way there's one
lesson in there which is my dad told me
something he goes look uh you're
building a small business and he goes
but look but think about it you're still
spending like every waking moment
thinking about how to make this thing
successful he goes if you worked on a
big business you don't have to spend
double the hours you're still going to
spend every waking moment trying to
think of how to make it successful a big
business and a small business both take
the same amount of time why would you
choose a small business and that to me
was the right advice for me for who I
was that's not the right advice for
everybody but like somebody out there
needs to hear that right now which is
that like this idea that a a small thing
is somehow easier or or less painful
it's just not true it is not true and it
it feels nice to be able to like pay
people a lot of money or hire a certain
type of person that makes your
day-to-day far more enjoyable um talk
about the naming thing my opinion has
changed on that to align with yours so
one one thing we have here is branding
or naming at the beginning so
um I evolved My Philosophy so I I used
to try to get the whole thing right
right away I was very precious about my
idea and I wanted it to my baby to be
cute and be ready for its first day of
school and then I realized that nobody
cares about my baby and I have no
customers and nobody's paying attention
this thing could be called dog crap you
know it doesn't matter uh until it
matters and so now here's the balance
that I figured out for me um in most
cases I try to get the name right off
the bat cuz changing the name is kind of
annoying you lose the brand recognition
um and I tried to get the trademark CU I
made that mistake before of not owning
my trademark and having to change my
name a year or two in because I realized
oh I'll never be able to sell this
without owning the trademark and so that
was a big mistake uh but I don't know if
that's true dude what do you mean I
don't own I I sold the hustle without
owning that trademark you didn't own a
trademark for the hustle as a media
company you didn't own anything because
I know they have it now we looked it up
they have it now but but what happens is
if they look and they see that they
can't get it cuz it's taken now you have
a problem now you're either going to get
negotiated down is that true I see I
didn't even know that like when Moyes
was selling native deodorant he didn't
own the trademark and it was an issue
he's got the deal done and they're like
wait you don't have the trademark he's
like yeah but there's no other native
deodorant they're like okay Junior what
are you talking about that's not how
this works um you know and so then he's
like okay uh who the he's like I'll just
go file for it they're like nope it's
taken by some guy some woman or some guy
sitting in Palo Alto doing nothing just
squatting on it and he goes to that
person he's like hey like the trademark
he tells the story on on his episode of
the Pod I think is like one of the first
10 episodes of this podcast but the
short version is he goes and he offers
the person some like you know he's like
hey can I have it and they're like no
and he's like okay I'll buy it like you
know for two grand and they're like no
and then they figured out that he's
selling his company and then that the
price went like way up and I think he
ended up having to buy it for like
either like A4 million or like one or
two million you had to buy the trademark
at the last minute that's so you know
fine when you're he's selling the
company for 100 million but like very
painful process um you know to to do
that better off just having it you
taught me something I I thought that
they were nonsense but I but I also used
to think name I mean look I my company
was called The Hustle that's a horrible
name one time I had this conference
called conon the content conference like
I'm I'm I I my first the first business
that I started making money online it
was called itch juice baby like I like
I'm horrible with names um and uh but
now I do actually think they're way
important before I was like names are
[__] it doesn't matter what you call
it someone's going to come uh now I'm
like on board with naming and branding
is is very valuable so I don't think a
bad name kills you but a good name lifts
you I completely agree I think great
design is a huge value ad and costs
almost nothing to have great design
versus okay to bad design it's not
actually more money that it takes it's
taste you just have to have the right
people to do it you can pay for that
taste like you can pay a fancy agency
because you know they have the taste but
you could also just have taste yourself
or find somebody that's cheaper that has
taste my feeling on design is I don't
start with fancy design I start with
like you know whatever simple design and
then I set a milestone almost as a
reward which is if we get to X then I'm
going to Fancy Pants my design cuz it's
more for me than it is really for
anybody else at that moment um but you
know if you're if you're consumer
package good or something like that then
the packaging obviously super important
if you're a SAS tool for whatever your
design uh you know doesn't matter as
much before I I launched Hampton I paid
an agency I found an awesome agency
overseas so it was like I think 15 or 20
grand and we did a whole branding thing
and I'm like I can't believe I'm doing
this and it was totally worth it did I
send you that presentation it was did
and I liked it um I was like oh this is
cool and that's different you wouldn't
have you would have never done that
before I have I never would have done
that it was totally worth it we both
were very um cheap with things before I
was I wasn't cheap with spending money
but I was cheap with my time meaning I
placed no value on my time and I think
you were cheap with spending money even
though you had a bunch of cash in the
bank not anymore then when I saw you
spend 20K on your branding before and I
was like oh that makes sense he's got a
killer name for his community Hampton
and then he's got like a really classy
design that makes it feel elevated which
is my word of the year um then I was
like oh yeah what are the areas where
I've been cheap and one of mine for
example was in recruiting so I used to
take pride in just recruiting Myself by
hand hunting and I would just be like
yeah I'm gonna go find people and I'm
gonna like message them and I'm G to
cold email them and I'm G to convince
them and I'm GNA interview them and I'm
gonna and now I hire recruiters and I'm
like oh for which roles for every role
anything if I if I need to hire first
thing I do I just text my recruiter this
guy Carson I'm like yo Carson I need X
and uh he's like a great Ecom recruiter
and so I'm like Carson I need I need X
and he's like on it and he's like super
aggressive and so he's just like
instantly will start sending me LinkedIn
I'm like yes no yes no he does is he a
full-time employee or do you just he
just he's got his own agency um he's his
own recruit he's his own solo shop and
so um so I use him to hire for these
roles and it just saves a ton of time
and then I'm able to and I have him
sometimes I'll be like yo join this call
so that you see what I ask so that when
you're screening candidates you just ask
these questions before me right and I'm
getting a way better result using
recruiters and yeah you pay the
commission when when when you hire the
person but like hiring a great person
faster is uh is totally worth it so how
do you without blowing up this guy at
Carson's spot how do you pay him do you
pay him a percentage same as all
recruiters you pay a percentage of their
first year salary and if they don't and
then do you pay them like six months
later uh I pay them up I think what I do
with him is I pay him like 30 days after
they join but if they don't work out
like like we had one person didn't
didn't work out three months in so if if
they don't make it three months then he
just reimburses or credits it back or
whatever and then do you um do you do it
for all like even an entry level
position everything anything I need
anything I need now I'm like what
whatever I would spend the time doing
this guy is going to spend all of his
time doing and um so it just moves
faster and he's better and I'm like why
the [__] wasn't I using recruit I used
to used to take pride and I was like
what am I trying to save here the like
you know let's say you hire somebody for
100 grand let's say the recruiter fee
might be 15 or 20 % so you're going to
pay 15 or 20 grand that's a lot of money
yes but I do it my bu if your business
is working then it makes total sense to
be using recruiters to increase your
pipeline and and save time and get the
get good butts and seats faster versus
trying to do it yourself that's time
you're not focused on the business that
takes
longer uh the biggest thing that's
changed with me with hiring is um
reference checks so like for example I
uh messaged someone two days ago I go
hey I'm thinking about um hiring this
one person uh do you think that they'd
be decent at managing a small team and
it says I don't think they could manage
anyone let alone themselves that was the
reply and my reply to my my reply to
that was uh all right thanks and I don't
hire that person like it's your rep to
that should be thank you so much what's
your address I'm sending you something
because most reference checks will not
give you honesty the when somebody goes
out on Lim is actually like yo let me
save you some pain here and give you my
honest truth even though it doesn't feel
good to take opportunity away from
somebody it's like you sweet baby Jesus
thank you so much I I owe you one so
like yeah I was like over the top like
nice to this guy but uh reference checks
are so important and I do two things
differently the one I always ask for
like three and then I call those three
and I go who else did this person work
with I don't give a [__] about the three
that they give me I'm just trying to
like I'm trying to like figure out who I
can reference who I can can speak to
that they didn't provide but also I
won't blow up the applicant spot where
if it's like you know it's like someone
who I that will be a little bit
secretive and not tell their current
employer um and then so I do that like
crazy and then here's what I ask
consistently here's how the basically
the point is is I want to hear bad [__]
about the person and I want to figure
out if the bad stuff is I'm okay with
and so I say what are they out of scale
one to 10 they always say an eight or a
nine and I say all right how can they be
a perfect 10 like what's missing and
then that's typically when they'll tell
me like bad stuff and I'm always looking
for that bad stuff and I'm like um well
uh you know they've made like mistakes
doing X Y and Z it's like okay I could
put up with those types of mistakes or
they um they um they like Miss deadlines
all the time I'm like well I I'm not
going to put up with Miss deadlines
that's I'm not willing to put up with
that so I like I do a [__] ton of
reference checks now so someone taught
me a good way to do reference checks I
don't remember the exact question but
it's something along there there's two
things that I do on the reference check
one is you're just trying to figure out
is this person one of the the best
people that they worked with at that
company and so I'll ask a question I ask
the following types of questions I'll
say you know my experience is that at
every company there's like you could
look around the room and there's two or
three people inevitably in every single
company who like they just have the team
on their back and you're just you just
look at them you think man if we didn't
have this person we would be in a rough
spot uh or like you know these things
these good things that are happening
just probably wouldn't have happened if
not for their force of will um and I
would be like you know who are the
people and I use this to recruit to I'm
like who are the people like that at
your compy or I'll be like would would
you count this person as one of those
people and um I I just try to see how
much conviction they have of being like
oh yeah for sure or like yeah you know
they're good right it's like you could
say yeah two different ways and I'm
looking for which one of those it is the
second thing I'll ask is I'll be like um
you know I'm thinking about hiring this
like I'm leaning towards hiring them uh
because I'm kind of trying to disarm
them I'm trying to not make them feel
like what they say is going to like mess
it up but I'll be like but you know but
what I don't but I don't feel
comfortable with this I don't know what
they're not good at and everybody has
things they're not good at I'm not sure
what I you know like I know that they
must have things that are going to
disappoint me or going to be uh things
that they're not strong at I just don't
know them yet what are they for this
person so I can kind of feel like I have
the full picture before I before I go
ahead and pull pull the trigger and hire
them and that's how I get them to kind
of tell me those things why' you write
paid tests what's that so my thing with
hiring is uh I would say two things have
improved my hiring number one
paid tests instead of interviews so I
will spend the time I'll spend 3 four
hours creating a paid test so I create a
doc that's here's a brief and I'll say
I'm going to pay you and depending on
the role might be two 200 bucks it might
be $2,000 I'll pay you to spend a day on
this um because I want to see what you
do because I just wrote words equal lies
it's like I don't really I'd rather just
see your work than hear you tell me that
you're good at work and so paid tests is
now I lean towards that in the end that
saved me a ton of time the second thing
I did I have a buddy who I let invest in
one of my companies that I didn't really
need as an investor but I kind of
thought I I kind of realized that like
as a CEO your job is just decision-
making good judgment over and over and
over are you the CEO of your Ecom
business um no I'm more like a chairman
so I'm not act day to-day now but um I
will I don't uh so what I'll do is I'm
like oh CEO's job is just
decision-making or any leader let forget
the word CEO just any Leader's job is
decision- making how do I get my
decision making to be better and like
the difference of making 10 to 20%
better decisions every single month adds
up that that creates a very different
outcome so I brought this guy in and I
and what I told him I go you know I
really want your help hiring and he's
like yeah sure I'll you know see if
there's anyone in my network I go no no
no I want you to do three interviews for
this one role for me I'm hiring a CMO
and I a chief marketing officer and I
think this is the make or break hire for
this business I want you on the call and
I want you to lead the interview and I
want to listen and so we did two things
first I would interview them separately
you you an investor you you let an
investor do that he's my one of my best
friends and yes he invested in my
company got it uh and he's he's himself
a founder and and whatever so he's just
got a lot of experience and he I've seen
him make great hires and so what
happened was I would interview them then
he would interview them I would like
them he'd be like no trash I'm like what
interesting uh what makes you say that
what did I like what did you what not
like and the thing for him was always
like uh yeah I pressed him for specifics
and he didn't have any he's like and
what I realized was he presses for
specifics way more than I was previously
doing so I would say like um I would try
to figure out do you have experience
doing this um you know how would you
rate yourself in this tell me a story
and they would tell me one story what he
would say is like um cool what did the
re what was the revenue when you started
what was it you know and then how did it
grow in the first 18 months and they're
like he's like if they don't even know
that number then they're out you know if
you're if you're CMO you don't know how
much of the revenue change from day one
to day you know month 12 or whatever
you're out then he's like they would say
the number he'd be like cool what were
the three things that you did that most
impacted
that and he's like you know if you can't
tell me three wins you've had in the
three years you've worked there that
like most impacted the and then he would
say oh you did that thing okay cool can
you screen share real quick and just
show me like uh you're saying you did
this can you just show me how you think
about this I want to hear you talk out
loud and I was like oh okay there's a
different level level of specificity
here that I need to be doing in my
interviews so a very useful thing was
seeing how a master does it so that I
could up my game that's kind of an
interesting thing because I've changed I
did to 180 what was your before what's
your
after I would create my before is I
would create like the most ambitious
goals um because it was just like it was
like mental masturbation of like just
using this spreadsheet and like saying
like yeah we're going to 3x this year
and five yeah five look at that yeah I'm
like I'd be like yeah can you like
change that three to a five and change
this zero to a nine and like it's like
boom we're there all right get after it
guys like and I didn't understand that
like a they're the one doing the work so
it's kind of [__] that I'm like
creating these crazy goals that there's
no math behind it I also thought that
like really ambitious goals were
inspiring um I I actually think uh
achievable goals are inspiring and I try
to hit like 75% of the goals that we set
if I'm if I'm not hitting about 80% um
my goal setting was quite bad so I I
hitting goals hitting hitting goals that
are not that ambitious I think gets you
a better outcome than missing incredibly
ambitious goals I like it creates more
momentum I agree with you momentum is
momentum is
key our software is the worst have you
heard of HubSpot see most crms are a
cobble to together mess but HubSpot is
easy to adopt and actually looks
gorgeous I think I love our new CRM our
software is the best HubSpot grow better
my goal thing now um so every time I
start a project whether it's a company
or inside of a company just like a
initiative I got this thing called the
kickoff dock it's a onepage doc that I
fill out religiously and it's basically
like starts with it's just like what are
we trying to do here we're trying to do
this in plain English what are we trying
to do then what does winning look like
and this is where I Set uh two goals so
I have a floor goal and what I call the
FIA goal the floor goal is basically
like you know if it was below this I'd
be surprised and I'd be a little
disappointed and then the FIA goal is
what would have us running around here
chest bumping being like Oh my God I
can't believe it happened and now I have
this range and I have kind of like my
men and my dream and of course we're
going to shoot for the dream but we're
going to make sure that we also
understand that like a win is a win and
anything above this floor is a win and
we have the two Targets and we ask
ourselves what would it take to get to
the floor what would it take to get to
the to the to the fbii goal to get to
the ceiling and so that's the first
thing I do the second thing I do is I
set an anti-g goal learned this from
Andrew Wilkinson which was yeah that was
smart you could achieve you know you
could double Revenue but if I wake up
every day and I'm stressed out or if I
doubled Revenue but profits went to zero
because I spent so much on marketing
well then I kind of lost while winning
so anti-g goals like you know I'm not
trying to work so hard I don't see my
kids right like in life I think anti-g
goals are really important to
counterbalance what and what the
specific thing here is what are
the understandable traps we could fall
into while trying to achieve those goals
so for example with this podcast you be
like oh I want a double re double
downloads great what's a trap you could
fall into every day I'm on the algorithm
trying to figure out what clickbaity
[__] I could do where I'm knocking on
neighbors doors asking them how they
made their money and then I pants them
and then I put a pie in their face like
yeah that would do it but I would sell
my soul and lose some dignity and not
have that much fun doing it so that's
like losing while winning so I think
anti-g goals are really important I
started doing those the next thing on
goal setting is I realize that much more
important than the goal like it's like I
would do these like big bursts where
it's like we do this planning and set
this goal then like three months later
it's like hey what's the goal and then
like it's not even on the tip of
anyone's tongue and I'm like oh [__]
this is backwards like first of all I
shouldn't be the one setting the goals
um because like you know in Game of
Thrones the opening scene where Ned
Stark has to like execute the guy and
his son is like oh do you have to do
this like can't someone else do this and
he says no like he who speaks the
sentence must swing the sword it's like
I can't expect you to go do all the work
for some goal I set sitting in my boxers
in Excel right like now it's like if I'm
going to set a marketing goal I'm going
to set it with and really like the CMO
has to own that goal they have to know
know that that's what they want that
that's what they think is achievable um
I'm going to push back or hold the
standard but they're going to ultimately
speak the sentence because they're going
to be the ones who swings the sword so I
make them do it and then the second
thing I do is I enforce that it's how do
we keep this top of mind and at the tip
of our tongue and that's like creating
rituals where we're seeing things daily
and weekly that um tracks to it because
it's far more important to regularly
look at the kpis and ask ask the right
questions versus
trying to set a great goal once and then
never thinking about it or not really
looking at it on a religious basis do
you lose your temper and yell have you
ever made someone cry like an employee
have you ever made an employee cry
because you've yelled at him not because
he no I never yell but uh I've never
made them cry because he yell never done
that I I've I don't think I've ever
yelled no um I could be I could be like
kind of I'll I could I'll curse like
I'll be like hold on like what the [__]
are we doing here right but it's more of
that just you never been like you're an
idiot you've never insulted someone or
beat them up or sure you know just punch
them in the face or just rude but I but
it's you know there's some finesse to my
rudess where it's like a it's a
backhanded slap not a front-and slap
type of thing there's been many times in
the past where I've lost my anger and
I'll be really just a huge [__] to
someone and
uh and
uh it's like I deeply regret that not
only do I regret that because it was
just silly but like so the way that I
used to like uh react to bad news is I
would um I would yell at people
sometimes and I would lose my temper and
I would freak out and I realize that
that is just so weak for so many that is
just a bad one you I I I I come to this
I've come to the conclusion I can't
change people so if I think someone is
just repeatedly not screwing up I I just
I shouldn't have hired them I made that
mistake I someone is either great
you you're normally a great executor who
sometimes makes mistakes or you're just
never going to change and you're just
not good like I think losers exist and I
don't want to surround myself with them
um that's kind of like my my attitude
like your sign it's like a a store
that's like you know no shoes no shirt
no service it's like losers exist we
must avoid them like keep them out yeah
like I think that that's real uh like
losers exist and sometimes I've been a
loser I tweeted this out when I was
working at twitch I go like right after
I left twitch I think I tweeted this out
I go well you know uh seems to be a
pattern you know basic there's a pattern
now which is that when someone's great
odds are they're great kind of right
away like um of course there are
exceptions but I would say the general
rule is that the best people I've ever
hired it's pretty obvious within 34
weeks that they're amazing and then they
just stay amazing and of the people that
were late bloomers the key there was
just the the only consistent pattern I
found was I hired somebody before I even
understood what role they should have or
what the role is and like when they had
an undefined role they didn't really do
very well but then when I defined a role
for them and I said look this is what
you got to do they performed and what I
found is that when I have a defined role
for someone and they're not very good it
never never really changes for me yeah
you can't change him you can't change
people and I used to be I used to lose
my temper and I would like curse and I
would and I definitely made people feel
stupid and that was that's such a bad
mistake because uh a that's just wrong
that's just not how you should treat
people but B that I'm not going to get
my desired outcome they're not going to
change exactly I I I still suck at that
I would be honest I'm not like a yeller
but I can make people feel small and I
kind of realized this the other day I
was like in every interaction you're
either going to walk away like you're
going to leave someone and they're
either going to feel a little bit like
they're going to feel either smaller or
bigger based on how that interaction
went how you treated them and I was like
damn I I think I've make people feel
small a lot and you know I'm I think I'm
doing it in service of like we're doing
dumb [__] we need to do the right
thing but I'm definitely not like I've
seen people who are really good at still
getting the thing done without ever
making people feel small and I want to
learn that Jedi who's an example who's
an example of someone who does that um
our buddy suly I think is pretty good at
that I don't know what he's like inside
of a company but like I've seen him kind
of like as a advisor type of guy and um
I know what he's thinking in the moment
I'm like oh man he's got to looking at
this being like what in the actual [__]
is going on here but that's not what
comes out of his mouth and he will
finesse his way there and I don't think
it's because he's a Kinder nicer person
I think it's cuz the last thing you said
which was I think he's realized that's
not how you get to your desired outcome
um that's not how you get the desired
outcome not at all uh exactly so so I
think that that's a that's definitely a
uh an area to to improve in fact like
the one time I did make somebody cry is
when I was firing somebody and I
realized in that moment I was like like
oh he's not crying cuz he's sad that
he's getting fired obviously there's
that part of it but he's very surprised
and that's on me like um I was too
scared
to be clear upfront that hey this isn't
going the way we need it to go and it's
got to go differently and here's what
the level is and this is not like this
currently not at the level and so I W I
avoided that tough conversation there
and now I'm having a tougher
conversation because I avoided that one
how many people have you fired
uh I don't know like
really yeah that's that's a lot right I
don't know I've been going for 16 years
like you one a year it's not not not
that not that much I've not fired that
many people I'm such a punk so there's a
story about Dave port there's a story
about Dave poroy and uh like Dave porno
is like I don't fire people like it's
impossible to get fired by me I ra I'll
just pay you and you just are lazy and a
bum and I'll just make fun of you and
it's good content I kind of feel the
same way I suck at firing I uh I have a
good script I basically say like right
off the bat I go all right this
conversation is going to stink but I'm
firing you today and we could talk about
why if you want um now I don't even say
why I'm just like this isn't working out
because it doesn't benefit me to say why
it only hurts you because I can sue you
but uh I'm horrible at firing people
like I I like I'm such a punk I like I I
I hate having that conversation that I
avoid it yeah but it's just like
anything else like you just stretch the
pain out longer versus rip the key is
and I say this because everybody who but
every manager everybody who becomes a
manager of any people like don't worry
you suck everybody sucks as a manager at
the beginning nobody is naturally just
like an amazing manager right off the
bat it is a learned skill and uh the key
to firing though if you learn nothing
else about firing uh is in the first 10
seconds you need to say the news just do
not beat around the bush uh you know the
reason we're here today is because we're
going to let you go and um you know that
has to come out of your mouth in the
first t seconds and if you say anything
else in the first 10 seconds just
realize you're being a complete [__]
cuz uh when it does come and they
realize wait what were you just saying
all that stuff about why didn't what and
you're going to Blindside them in a much
worse way it's it's key absolutely key
um I have a couple other areas I want to
ask you about one is I think probably
the key to making [__] work keeping
things simple and focused so knowing
what to say yes to and what to say no to
do you have anything that you actually
do
to make that to like do that better now
I think that I'm so good at focus and
I'm bad at it I've missed a lot of
interesting opportunities but by default
I say no to everything and it's actually
cost me um a bunch um like for example
um at the hustle we thought about
launching multiple newsletters and I was
like nope we're just going to do this
one thing we're going to do it well
because Scott bsky told me to focus and
to only do this one thing so I'm
literally going to say no to everything
and our competitor did and they scaled
the revenue significantly faster so I
said no to Too Much actually but um my
my default was just I'm gonna say no to
everything that's interesting I'm the
opposite I'm a shiny object you know
syndrome kind of guy and so by the way
the hustle didn't we didn't even have an
Instagram handle until like four years
in like I like I was like no we're not
going to do social media we're doing
nothing it was like we're doing nothing
we're just going to do this one stupid
newsletter all the time lunch
no dude one of my biggest one of my
speaking of by the way I used to be
really cheap one of deep in my soul the
thing that hurts me most is one time I
bought all the supplies from Costco for
a conference and I ended up returning
$2,000 worth of like canned soda and
stuff and like the lady at the front
desk was like you're
pathetic because I was like what and
she's like you know we throw all this
stuff away is this just some from some
party that you threw and it was like my
answer was even worse which was like no
it's for a business conference that made
a lot of money and like and like it
hurts my soul that I was so cheap that I
returned open cans of soda to Costco for
$2,000 it that like crushes me like like
the 24 like the 24 case was like uh
things yeah and and like I was like I
can't believe that was such a punk move
I can't believe I did that uh that's one
of my biggest regrets that's next to
this one time I tipped this taxi driver
and he said oh no you don't need to do
this and I said oh no you need it
instead of you earned it like those two
things are like the two things that like
Crush my soul I'm like I can't believe I
said that um but what what what were you
saying you were talking about um focus
what were you talking about Focus
[__] a
focus as we get back on
track um I create I I now have a thing
which is I I create a a a dock for every
business every year that's called the
big bets doc which is basically like we
we are going to make some bets this year
we're going to do some things um but
let's be super um conscious about what
we're saying yes to and what we're
saying no to so my big bet stock and
I'll literally write it like this I'll
say something
like we uh bet number
one um we really suck at inventory
management today forecasting is just me
looking at the spreadsheet and making up
numbers based on what I hope happens uh
I know there's probably a smarter way to
do this other people certainly have
solved this problem um I need to figure
out how to hire people who know how to
do this so the bet is I'm going to hire
two people and that's going to lower our
waste from X to Y and I write a sentence
like that and then that's my bet I'm
going to make this higher for this
outcome because of this problem and I
write a bet number two um you know you
keep talking about businesses though are
you what how many are you what how many
well like I I would do this even for the
podcast right like big bets right um
hiring Ari okay why why why did you do
this why did you make this bet or we
just launched the clips Channel okay why
am I going through this effort where I'm
sitting here clipping my favorite parts
of podcasts because I hope that somebody
out there wants just listen to the best
parts on YouTube when they come up
because that's how I like to listen to
things and so I'll write it out and I'm
like if I'm going to invest my effort my
time my money into something uh then I
write it out or like you know maybe it's
for shepher for Shephard hey here's the
bets that we're going to make um and so
I'll do this exercise because it's so
useful so I write the big bets and it's
like here's the three to four big bets
that we're going to make the things that
we're going to bet on that we're going
to do that we're going to invest in and
we're going to try to do really really
well and then I'll make the no list
right before that and the no list I
write there are a bunch of other things
that we could talk ourselves into doing
that are easily justifiable however
we're going to say no to these things
this year because we want to do the we
actually want the things above to happen
and then I'll make make the no list
here's the things we're not going to do
this year that we totally could have
talked ourselves into so for me that was
a very useful exercise and then when I
bring people on everybody I sit down
with them with this big bets list I'm
like here's what we're doing and then if
they're the one responsible for it I'm I
treat it like a commercial because I'm
like I need to make this memorable I
need this person to wake up and remember
is it's not just for me to be focused I
need my whole team to be focused how do
I do that I basically shrink down one of
these bets into a almost like a like a
slogan or a jingle for their role it's
like your your mission is this remember
that and I'm going to say that to you
probably a hundred times in the next
three months and um we're just going to
keep checking in on that and that's how
I'm going to bonus you is if you did
that or not and that's how I'm going to
assess your performance is if you did
that or not and if I ever if if I ever
what's the priority it's that that's the
priority and I took this because like
Peter teal said that he did this at
PayPal he's like yeah I don't know
whatever Management's not my favorite
thing so here's my shortcut to
management everybody at any time has one
priority and if you ever try to talk to
me about not that priority I will just
simply leave the room I thought that was
just the visual of that was so funny to
me what a [__] weirdo I was like
Peter can you can you be normal for what
like if someone walked up W stood up and
walked away when I was telling telling
them about stuff I'm like dude can you
just be noral idea about a new program
that we could do and he just like drifts
away like a hot air
balloon what a weirdo man
stories there's sto there's stories of
Elon doing that too where like in an
interview like within 30 seconds he
would be like Oh I'm not interested in
this person and so he would just hang
up yeah he emailed out at Tesla see the
laptop closing he was like um if you're
in a meeting and in the first few
minutes of the meeting you realize that
this is not useful to you or to anybody
please stand up and leave uh like your
time is valuable these meetings are
drain and uh vote with your feet just
get up and go that is a completely
acceptable behavior here at Tesla
do you ever send emails with with the
one of those emails where the subject is
the body of the email yeah of course
it's just like a pager basically you're
treating it like a pager I had one of
the only jobs I ever had my boss sent me
an email like that and I was like is
this how we send emails and then I I I
sent them an email I go what's the
status on this this thing and it was in
the subject and the reply was don't ever
send me an email like this again uh it
was I love Emil I I actually I think
there are those levels so basically what
I realized is that rich people and busy
people treat email like texting so their
email is like lowercase on their phone
on line totally fine that's like their
normal way of of emailing and
then Mega rich people treat email like
it's letters they'll have somebody
actually screen them print them out and
then they'll kind of like review them at
their desk in paper this is like the old
school way of of of doing things who do
you know who does that I think Mark Lor
does that if I had to guess feel like he
did tell us that uh Trump does that well
no he told us he didn't even own a
computer he didn't own a computer yeah
but like I i' I've met a couple people
one of my old bosses used to do that
like he used to print out his important
his assistant would print out his
important emails and just put them on
his desk so that he could like see them
and he would just leave a sticky note on
them and she would go figure out what to
do um I you know I worked for a guy who
had four women at the office with giant
TV screens just managing his inbound
emails and he would just stand and walk
around they would be like oh this person
said this they pull it up on the screen
he would just orally dictate his reply
and then he would walk away and then
they would just keep managing it it was
insane man most of the day I feel like
I'm responding to stupid ass messages
like on slack Twitter text email it I
cannot stand it man it is so hard so I
actually think printing out that thing
and replying could be kind of cool
actually yeah or creating you need some
kind of firewall like for me it's like
my assistant is the firewall she triages
all the emails and then I only check my
email for 30 minutes a day like you know
cuz it's already taken care of of and if
there's something that needed a faster
reply she'll tell me she'll text me and
then that's it um uh there was one other
thing that I was going to share which
is
um there's a big difference I think
that's worth saying which is pre-product
Market fit and post so pre-product
Market fit what you do versus post is
very different I think most of this call
has been about post but actually like
most of my life has been about before
you have product Market fit before you
have product Market fit you don't do any
of these things you literally just
figure out what your product is and you
go try to sell it and get customers and
then you basically get rejected and you
know you handle that and you iterate
until you figure out what the product
should be and who the customer should be
and you've proven how to get product and
customers to go up um you to connect and
and get more customers like I think
that's worth saying too and then after
you have figured that out after you have
figured out that this product actually
has a market and you know how to
communicate it to customers you know how
to get customers then you hire people
ble to like do more of that and I would
say like I saw you firsthand with
Hampton doing this we're like there was
a couple months where you showed me your
calendar and it looked like a Jenga
Tower it was 20 minute calls stacked on
top of each other sometimes overlapping
and I was like what is this like where
do and you're like yeah I'm trying to go
get the members for Hampton I'm trying
to figure out what Hampton is and you
you sent me like a like a kind of a
script or like a landing page you were
writing it yourself trying to explain
what the benefits are and who it's for
and you considered like you know should
I take this angle or this angle or this
angle and I like would help you like
reply on the Google Doc well it's kind
of like U it's kind of like being a
comedian you know what I'm saying like
when when Hassan minhaj finally does his
Netflix show he's done 200 before that
and you see which angle hits and it's
the same thing it's like I got to see
which which angle is hitting um someone
tweeted out or something they're like um
product Market product Market fit is
like sex if you have to ask you're not
having it or something like that and I
was like that's so stupid I've
definitely asked in both of those
situations if I have it or
not I was like that's one of those lines
that's one of those lines that sounds
good but uh that ain't true I was
uncertain multiple times about both of
them
things is it happening is this it is
this happening are we doing
it and that so that's the
[Music]
pod